new front and the fighting in is
developing in southwest ukraine this
morning british military intelligence
says russia is moving convoys of tanks
and weapons from the east to prepare for
the battle this as ukraine is
increasingly targeting bridges and
russian ammunition dumps in the region
charlie dagetta is in the southern port
city of odessa which has been under
russian the russian siege and is now
finally able to ship much needed grain
worldwide charlie good morning
good morning that first convoy of grain
ships set sail from these ports
yesterday carrying 60 thousand tons of
corn but further north a dangerous game
is underway trading blows over europe's
largest nuclear power plant
smoke rises from electric pylons at the
zaparisia power plant as both sides
blame each other for shelling that
downed high voltage power lines
prompting engineers to pull the plug on
one of six reactors
russian forces captured the compound in
the early stages of the war back in
march but ukrainians still operated
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
accusing russia of using a plant as a
weapon
any shelling of this facility is an open
brazen crime an act of terror he said
fighting has raged in this region as
both sides prepare for a showdown over
the strategic front-line city of
mikalive the target of nightly
bombardment
the shelling is happening all the time
ludmila clemenco said the school was
burned down over there
this russian missile strike on the
regional government headquarters
happened in the first few weeks of the
war but the bombardment has continued in
fact it's intensified in the past few
days
russia's ministry of defense released
this video showing its soldiers in
combat opening fire with rocket
propelled grenades and while russia may
have promised safe passage of grain at
sea
it's still open season on land rockets
hit a grain silo in the zaparisa region
yesterday destroying more than 350 tons
of sunflower seeds according to the
grain company manager and military
spokesperson natalia humanuke told us
russian missiles continue to target
odessa ports despite the grain deal mama
is probably
it is a demonstration of their brute
force she said we have no trust in the
russians so we have to rely on
international guarantees and support
now we're back here in odessa after
visiting mikalive yesterday we had to
leave after they imposed a 48-hour
lockdown the governor told us part of a
special operation to root out russian
collaborators nancy
charlie thank you